- [Voiceover] All right, we
have a wordy question here.
The global temperature anomaly
indicates how much warmer
or colder the average
global temperature is
than normal during a particular time.
A researcher conducting
an observational study
charted and analyzed
atmospheric carbon dioxide,
CO2 levels and the global
temperature anomaly
in degrees celsius since the year 1960.
The researcher observed
that the rate of ...
okay this is the part that
seems to get interesting.
The researcher observed
that the rate of increase
of atmospheric CO2, carbon dioxide,
since 1960, approximately
four percent per decade,
is comparable to the rate of increase
in the global temperature anomaly
during the same time period.
Approximately 3.9 percent per decade.
Based on this data, which
conclusion is valid?
All right, let's see.
There is a correlation
between the increase
in atmospheric CO2 levels since 1960
and the increase in the
global temperature anomaly
during the same time period.
That one seems pretty valid.
These are both moving in
the same direction together.
That's what correlation tells us.
It doesn't mean that
necessary the CO2 levels
are causing the temperature to increase,
or that the temperature
increase is causing the
CO2 levels to increase.
It's just saying that look over this time
we're seeing that these two
things are moving together,
which is what correlation is taking about.
How much do these data
points move together?
I'm liking this one.
I'm liking this one, so I'll ...
actually, let me read all of
them before I pick that choice.
The increase in the
global temperature anomaly
since 1960 caused the
increase in atmospheric
CO2 levels during the same time period.
Well, we don't know that.
We don't know whether
there is causality here.
Just by looking at that data,
these two things moving together,
you can't say that the temperature caused
the CO2 to move up.
This is one of the classic things
that a lot of times when
two things correlate
people want to show that
there's some causality.
It's much harder to show causality
than it is to show correlation.
I definitely don't like that.
The increase in atmospheric CO2 levels
since 1960 caused the increase in
global temperature anomaly
during the same time period.
Well, that might be a
reasonable hypothesis,
but that data doesn't tell us that.
It doesn't tell us.
There might have been some other cause
that caused both of those
two things to go up,
or this might have just
been two things that
happened to move together,
but is wasn't because of any
kind of causation one way or another.
You can't say that.
Just based on the data we have,
the fact that they both
increased at roughly four percent
per decade since 1960.
You can't say that one caused the other.
There is no correlation
between the increase
in atmospheric CO2 levels since 1960
and the increase in the global temperature
anomaly during the same time period.
No, they're for sure is a correlation.
You would say there's no correlation if in
some decades CO2 went up,
and the temperature went down,
while in other decades they both went up,
and other decades they both went down,
that would be no correlation.
If actually every time one of them went up
the other one went down,
that would be a negative correlation.
If they move together,
that is just a very strong
positive correlation.
No correlation would be
if you could, you know,
sometimes when one moves up,
the other one moves up or down,
when the other one moves up or down,
the other one moves up or down.
I don't know if that last
thing I said just made sense.
There was definitely a correlation.
They were moving together.
They're both increasing and
roughly at the same rate
over per decade since 1960.
I would rule that one out.
So yep, I feel good about
with our first choice.